[Music]
there is a national dilemma on this and
a real debate of whether in particular
to test sexual assault kids from
acquaintances rapes and we did a
cost-benefit analysis of this found for
every dollar you spend testing a sexual
assault kit you save eighty one dollars
on average to avert future sexual
assaults there's always been a moral
argument to test this large backlog of
sexual assault kits and now we've busted
buttress that argument with a strong
economic argument
unfortunately what has happened often in
the past is that the hospital sends the
kid to the police department and there
are currently around 400,000 sexual
assault kids just sitting in warehouses
in police departments throughout the
country so think about that 400,000
sexual assault victims go through this
incredibly unpleasant exam after a
traumatic sexual assault they do it so
that they hope they will find the
offender by doing by doing this and then
the kid just is sitting around and they
never investigated at all
when a victim of a sexual assault goes
to the police department the police
encourage them to go get him to the
hospital to get a medical forensic exam
and there the nurses try to get some
foreign DNA from the victim and they
take these swabs and put them in a box
and that's called a sexual assault kit
and then the hospital sends it back to
the police department and ideally what
happens at that point is that the Police
Department sends it to a lab the lab
tries to get DNA from these swabs if
they get DNA they run it against the
national database of felons and they try
to get a hit and if they get a hit
against that database of the DNA and the
swab is the same as the DNA in the
database then ideally this hit would
become a conviction you'd actually put
someone in jail
the cost of testing a sexual assault kit
is around $1,600 and the average amount
that we save by testing is about a
hundred and thirty thousand dollars
which is 81 times bigger than the 1600
so again every dollar we spend we're
saving about eighty one dollars that's
an incredibly conservative number the
actual number instead of eighty one is
probably a couple thousand because the
chances of conviction are now are much
higher than they were in the data that
we estimated from New York because the
statute of limitations are much larger
now in most states
there's many other benefits from testing
them testing these kids that we didn't
quantify so one big one is we didn't
quantify the costs associated with non
sexual crimes which are actually larger
than the costs associated with future
sexual assaults because these people on
average commit more non sexual crimes
than sexual crimes it also brings
closure to the victims it also an
interesting study people found that it
helps deter future crimes if you
actually get the kit and you put this
person into the database that once this
person finds out they're in the database
they will commit fewer future crimes
there are some people out there are just
serial sexual offenders and not just
sexual offenders but many other violent
non sexual felons and we have the
technology we have the wherewithal we
know how to get them off the street we
just haven't done it and there's an easy
way to get some of these people off the
street and we should do it
[Music]
you
[Music]